hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
this is financial freedom you have been
dreaming of it ever since you started
your working career almost 10 years ago
now
one day your friend introduces you to an
interesting website from a company
called terraform labs it's low risk
investment where you can earn 20 a year
on your deposits
if you just put in 500 from every
paycheck you'll make some decent returns
but you're skeptical and you dismiss it
but later when you think about the money
that's left sitting in your savings
account getting eaten away by inflation
you think to yourself maybe this is
worth a shot
the website states that it's using a
technology called stablecoins you don't
really know what that is but your friend
says it's pretty much risk-free but
little did you know that in just two
years you would lose half your savings
this is a story that's painfully
familiar to millions of others around
the world in total 45 billion dollars
worth of everyday people's money was
lost in less than a week
around the internet people are calling
this the 2008 crisis of crypto and now
you're right in the middle of it how
could this have happened to you this is
a horror story that many are living
right now
fusion tv
this is dokwan he's the one in charge of
the company that caused your financial
demise
born in south korea in 1991 do kwan was
a bright kid and went on to study
computer science at stanford graduating
in 2015.
he briefly worked for apple and
microsoft reportedly only for a few
months each
he would return back to south korea in
2015.
it would seem that working for big tech
wasn't enough for kwan he wanted to be
big tech itself but in the crypto space
not long after this he would hear of a
stablecoin project called basis he
looked into the idea of stablecoins and
saw them as the next big thing in
finance
the idea is that these tokens would
maintain a one us dollar value this is
called a peg
essentially the tokens would act like a
digital dollar
stable coins are for people that still
want to enjoy the benefit of crypto but
without all the wild swings in price
an interest rate system also makes sure
that depositors get rewarded for keeping
their money in the system
to get his idea off the ground it wasn't
going to be easy for quan he needed a
lot of funding to get started
stablecoin tokens are usually backed by
securities like treasuries and cash
reserves or with some combination of
other crypto people really want to have
confidence in knowing that a stablecoin
is worth what it says it is
instead of a traditional backing with
something like cash terror used an
experimental algorithm to help back the
system but more on that shortly
after a failed startup in january of
2018 dayquan and co-founder daniel sim
came up with the idea for terraform labs
eventually terra managed to get off the
ground with the support of 15 e-commerce
companies in asia
here is dou kwon talking about his ties
with the e-commerce platform chai in
2019 but in the back end is where the
real magic starts to happen and i
contend that terra solves two of the
biggest roadblocks to the adoption of
digital payments in asia and the rest of
the world
up up to today we've had 430 000 uh
shoppers over the chai payment gateway
most of them coming in the last month
and we've processed nearly 2 million
transactions up to date in terms of
daily active users
terra and chai has already surpassed
some of the most popular tokens
in 2019 kwon was named in asia's forbes
30 under 30.
but all was not as it seemed on the
surface according to some staff that i
talked to with interro labs do kwan was
narcissistic but charismatic he would
micromanage and sometimes verbally abuse
teralab staff
within one to two years virtually all
the core people left most with legal
disputes
as this happened terra labs increasingly
became a one-man show with dokwan making
all the decisions kwon's decisions would
eventually lead to the collapse and a
loss of billions
and time again low-risk so-called
algorithmic stable coins have been tried
with catastrophic results take mark
cuban for example he lost money on the
now dead titan iron stablecoin
so dokwan had a lot of work to do to get
people trusting and using terror
critics of stablecoins have called them
quote modern day pyramid schemes with
people like senator elizabeth warren
calling for regulation
this next section may seem a little bit
in the weeds but bear with me because
it's integral to understanding what
later went wrong the main focus of the
teralabs blockchain was their token
terra usd or ust which would stay stable
at one us dollar's worth of value
the terra system used two tokens to
function
ust was to remain stable while the other
token called luna was meant to absorb
volatility
one can buy ust on market exchanges or
through exchanging luna within the
system
at all costs the system tries to keep
everything in equilibrium
there were also financial incentives for
people to trade and swap lunar and ust
in whichever direction helps the system
stay in equilibrium
an algorithm is in charge of managing
all of this and making sure that it all
works
there's a major problem though the
system is designed to do this no matter
what happens to ust's market price on
other exchanges
if the peg begins to slip risk begins to
pile up people may jump out of the ust
token into other stable coins which
causes the lunar token to fall the
algorithm then prints more luna in order
to keep the peg so the price drops even
more this is okay for small dips but if
the selling pressure is too much then
there can be a feedback loop of people
selling and the system printing evermore
luna to try and keep the balance this is
called a death spiral
but this wasn't all there was yet
another issue with the system it had
grown too fast
investors who deposited ust into the
terror system were receiving roughly 20
yield this high return was what
attracted many people to the service in
the first place and terror grew rapidly
because of it but perhaps too rapidly
instead of the market deciding interest
rates do kwan wanted this rate fixed to
achieve this it was partly subsidised by
the company however as demand grew more
and more money needed to be paid out
around seven million dollars was paid
out in interest every day
dokwan also made a fatal mistake of
letting people take out their deposits
at any time perhaps what he didn't
foresee is that the rapid growth meant
that the system was extra vulnerable to
mass withdrawals all at once
unknowingly he had just caused both
major elements that would contribute to
the disaster the rapid and massive
growth thanks to the attractive fixed 20
return and the risk of mass withdrawals
many skeptics criticized terror stating
that it was unsustainable but devout
supporters or lunatics as they called
themselves would dismiss the criticism
do kwan was now the leader of a devout
group he had made people a lot of money
and it seemed like his reinvention of
finance was on its way to changing the
world
it was a safe crypto bank with a higher
interest rate and large adoption
in 2021 as the wider crypto market began
to turn south the yields and other
stable coins and tokens began to fall
but dokwan's fixed 20 yield on ust
became increasingly attractive and more
people piled in
by april of 2022 the lunacoin was
trading at over 100 us dollars a token
and the whole system was valued at 45
billion dollars
the terra luna system was being used in
hundreds of decentralized apps and
millions of payments around the world
with terror it finally looked like
decentralized finance had finally gone
mainstream
it should be noted that although the
terror system was marketed as
decentralized and coin holders did have
voting rights in reality it was the
opposite according to insiders dokwan
was a dictator and made all the final
decisions and influenced the direction
of the company effectively it couldn't
be more centralized
to fortify confidence in the system
terror labs built up resistance to
unexpected shocks they dedicated a
reserve of 450 million dollars and one
billion dollars worth of bitcoin to
defending the peg
at this point terra had the fourth
largest market cap in the whole of
crypto they looked unstoppable
as the use of terror expanded and
institutional investment arrived quan
got more cocky
i wonder how many of these companies you
think are entering the space just
because it's hot and there's a lot of
funding versus the ones that will still
be here you know like two to five years
later 95 were gonna die yeah ninety-five
percent are back tonight
uh but uh yeah there's also
entertainment from watching companies
tattoo
there's entertainment oh man that's
that's that's so evil at least you get
to learn from it right
on twitter he was also showing his
confidence the twitter user our god bet
one million dollars that in one year
from now tara luna would essentially
collapse
the stakes got raised to 10 million
dollars and put on the blockchain for
everyone to see
but behind the scenes things were
already going awry according to
documents filed by kwon at the supreme
court of south korea's registry office
kwon filed to dissolve the korean
company's entity on the 30th of april
2022 and was granted approval on the 4th
of may 2022 just days before the crash
for those that had put their hard earned
money into the system this should have
been a concern but they either weren't
paying attention or the pull of
financial freedom and peace of mind was
too strong this event should have been
the final red flag
[Music]
beginning on the 9th of may 2022 people
began to notice something strange
the one dollar peg promised by luna on
their ust token began to come undone
headlines were made when ust began to
break from its secure peg of one us
dollar
the disaster began to kick off with a
series of major withdrawals from the
interest yielding ust system according
to coindesk the amount was around 4
billion
a single wallet also dumped 84 million
worth of ust on the ethereum blockchain
and 108 million dollars on the binance
crypto exchange
these led calls from within the
community that the dpec was a
coordinated attack but people couldn't
worry about that now as things went from
bad to worse ust starts trading at 90
cents then 85 cents the peg was really
failing over the coming hours panic sets
in and some users pull their money out
conspiracy theories begin to take root
online what exactly is happening here
then even more users try to pull out
their funds this time all at once the
network becomes congested
the luna foundation guard an
organization that's supposed to support
the terror ecosystem announces a 1.5
billion emergency loan to restore the
peg to the us dollar but it doesn't work
ust falls to 50 cents then 20 cents a
far cry from its stable one dollar
promise
luna is also crashing it's seventy
dollars then twenty dollars then ten
dollars the hyper inflation of luna was
happening right before everyone's eyes
luna collapsed further to five cents
now virtually zero
unbelievable
ust now sits at a measly 10 cents
the collapse wiped out almost 45 billion
dollars of market capitalization luna
went down from an all-time high of 119
to virtually zero
the us government gets involved
immediately after the crash treasury
secretary yellen points to the ust
disaster and demands legislation by the
end of the year
on the 13th of may terraform labs halts
the terror blockchain the company's
attempts to stabilize the system also
fail
quan takes to twitter saying he's
heartbroken by the events
nobody has ever seen anything like this
before a top five crypto project going
to zero so quickly it was a true lehman
brothers moment for the crypto community
so who did it
according to some insiders i've talked
to those within teralabs believed that
this was a coordinated large-scale
attack which is viewable on the
blockchain from on-chain data one or two
actors bought a massive amount of ust
with bitcoin and then dumped that ust on
the market
these actors did so even at a loss just
to bring the system down
lucas our tomorrow head of research at
into the block told fortune quote the
large withdrawals appeared to be timed
precisely at the moment when luna was
most vulnerable end quote he checked the
data himself and said that it all lines
up and quote it is certainly suspicious
i think we are beyond the point that
this idea of an attack is just
speculation
unfortunately for those involved the
pieces were in place and the dominoes
were set up to fall once the price began
to drop people panic sold and the
algorithm tried to print more luna
reducing the price even further in a
runaway death spiral
many suspect that the perpetrator was a
large hedge fund but solid evidence is
yet to be found this may change as the
investigation continues there may be
some factors that we don't know about
that may come to light did the market
collude
to make this crash
happen this appears to be
a hedge fund
we don't know all people are naming the
hedge fund but i won't the trade was
instigated by one person and then we
don't know if the momentum was created
by collusion conspiracy theories would
say yes because it's a massive trade
there was a bit over a billion dollars
in capital
and then the market is saying that then
they ended up going short ust so that
they took a massive risk to achieve what
they did i mean people are saying they
made 950 million dollars
when all was said and done one million
dollars invested in terror just a week
before the crash is now worth a measly
three dollars
lives were ruined and dreams crushed all
over the internet there were devastating
stories of luna holders youtuber ksi
lost 2.8 million dollars another
youtuber karl roonfeld lost 1.4 million
but everyday people were also harmed in
this
reddit became populated with tragic
stories
one user writes i lost over 450 000 us
dollars i cannot pay the bank i will
lose my home soon i'll become homeless
suicide is the only way out for me it is
truly sad to consider those who have
been affected
due to the magnitude of the disaster dou
kwan has been likened by journalists to
elizabeth holmes of theranos especially
in his native country of south korea
but in a twist things may be a bit more
nuanced it is true that the success got
to dokwan's head he thought he was
better than everyone else and took
decisions solo
but according to insiders his decisions
were risky and ultimately hurt people
but he didn't want to defraud anyone he
loved control and power but he had a
reputation to keep and cheating people
would destroy that
ryan silkas founder and ceo of mesurai
states quote what happened to terror
wasn't fraud it was overconfidence in
the investors of last resort who had
already backed the project and reckless
growth at a time when the market was
slowing down end quote
so people may have that sentiment but
ultimately i think the blame cannot land
on anyone else but do kwan
kevin zhao of galeos capital on twitter
predicted the exact crash but dokkon
dismissed him a perfect example of his
careless attitude
others also predicted the crash here's
an eerily accurate prediction made in
december of 2019 at a blockchain
conference i think that um the biggest
risk the thing that could go really
massively arrive with stable coins that
could be terrible for the crypto world
overall is if there's an algorithmic
staple coin that has no backing that
just has a sort of algorithmic mechanism
um but but there there's a category
called algorithmic stable coins i would
put terra and cello in this category
there are a number of others basis was
like this and they never launched um
the thing that could happen
is one of those could launch and be
marketed very effectively and be
significantly adopted it could even
happen in a market where people really
really need a stable currency and don't
have one and that's why it gets
massively adopted people who are not
crypto speculators people who just want
to preserve their savings
if that protocol then blows up
economically and falls apart and the
price of that goes you know down half or
close to zero military backlash imagine
if we were sitting here today talking
about how great our stable coins were
where it had already been the case that
like a billion dollar stable coin had
collapsed and lots of innocent people
had lost their money you know it would
be a very different situation um and and
that really could happen there are
economic experiments being run with some
stable coins that i believe personally
could go that direction and so i think
the worst thing that could happen is if
one of those gets really big before it
fails yeah why people will use that tara
will tell you that like hundreds of
thousands of people in korea are using
it it's also possible that the whole
crash could have been avoided if those
20 yielding deposits in ust had a
withdrawal waiting time maybe seven days
or a month so that panics like this
wouldn't be possible
as for the future of stable coins trust
is broken even other projects that are
more responsible than do kuan's was are
going to take the heat and it's going to
take a lot of faith for people to trust
them again
the saddest thing in all of this is that
stable coins were seen as safe
people were using them as a bank account
to store their savings and earn interest
when a regular bank wouldn't provide
that much
these people were actively trying to
avoid the crazy speculation of the
crypto market
instead they found themselves in the
biggest crypto disaster of all to anyone
watching who was affected i hope you do
find some solace somehow for everyone
else watching from the sidelines may
this be a lesson in every investment no
matter how safe it seems if there's a
counterparty risk you should follow the
number one rule of investing only put in
what you're prepared to lose
so what happens to dokwan
well investors are very angry and
they're going to be wanting some answers
perhaps there'll be a class-action
lawsuit but for now we just don't know
just as i was finishing up this episode
dokuan announced terra 2.0 but the
reaction was overwhelmingly negative
so i'd like to hear from you guys did
any of you lose any money would you ever
trust stable coins again
let me know your thoughts in the comment
section below
so if you did like this episode instead
of subscribing search or scroll through
the cold fusion channel and take a look
and see if there's another topic that
you'll be interested in there's plenty
of stuff on here
alright so thanks my name is dagogo and
you've been watching cold fusion and
i'll catch you again soon for the next
episode
cheers guys
have a good
[Music]
cold fusion
it's new thinking